We just saw an example where visual spatial knowledge by itself,
suffices too in our logical reasoning under certain conditions.
Now let us look at a different problem. There suddenly are situations where we
might want AI agents to be able to extract [UNKNOWN] presentations.
Your projects one, two, and three did exactly that. One task,
where AI agent might want build proper [INAUDIBLE] representations out of
regional spatial knowledge is when an AI is given a design drawing. So
here is a vector graphics drawing of a simple engineering system.
Perhaps some of you can recognize what is happening here. This is a cylinder and
this a piston. This is the rod of the piston. The piston moves. Left and
right. The other end of the rod is connected to a crankshaft.
As this piston moves left and right, this particular crankshaft starts moving
anticlockwise. This device translates linear motion into rotational motion.
I just gave you a causal account. Although because [INAUDIBLE] only implicit in
this [INAUDIBLE] spatial knowledge. You and I were able to extract a causal
account out of this. How did we do it? How can we help AI agents do it?
At present if you were to make a CAD drawing using any CAD tool that you want,
the machine does not understand the drawing. But can machines of tomorrow
understand drawings by automatically building these causal models out of them?
Put it another way. There is a story that has been captured in this particular
diagram. Can a machine automatically extract the story from this diagram?
In 2007, Patrick Yaner built an AI program called Archytas. Archytas was
able to extract causal models out of vector graphics drawings of the kind that I
just showed you. This figure is coming from paper and Archytas and
hence the form of the figure. We'll have a pointer to the paper in the notes.
This is how Archytas works. It began with a library of source drawings.
These were drawings that we already knew about. For each drawing order it
knew about it already had done the segmentation. The basic shapes for
example might be things like circles and the composite shapes which were then
labeled like piston and cylinder. Then a behavioral model or
a causal model which said what happens when the piston moves in and
out, namely the crankshaft turns. And then a functional specification we've said
this particular system can work in linear motion into rotational motion. So
there was a lot of knowledge with each previous drawing that Archytas already
had seen. All of this knowledge was put into a library. When a new drawing was
input into Archytas then it generated line segments and arcs and
intersections from it. And then, it started mapping them to the lines and
segments and arcs of previously known drawings.
Retrieve the drawing that was the closest match in drawing to the new drawing.
And then started transferring basic shapes, and then composite shapes, and
it transferred each element through this abstraction hierarchy all the way up to
the functional level. As an example, if Archytas library contains piston and
crankshaft drawings like this along with causal functional models for
them, then given a new drawing of a piston and
crankshaft device Archytas will then be able to assemble a causal
functional model for the new drawing. Thus Archytas extracted causal
information from which spatial presentations to analogical reasoning.